in the last couple of videos we first
figured out the total variation in these
nine data points right here and we got
that to be 30 that's our some of our
total sum of squares and we asked
ourselves how much of that variation is
due to variation within each of these
groups versus variation between the
groups themselves for so for the
variation within the groups we had our
sum our sum of squares within and there
we got six and then the balance of this
30 there's no units here the balance of
this variation came from variation
between the groups and we actually
calculated it we actually calculated it
and we got 24 what I want to do in this
video is actually use this type of
information these essentially these
statistics we've calculated to come to
do some to do some inferential
statistics to come to some type of
conclusion or maybe not to come to some
type of conclusion and what I want to do
is just to put some context around these
groups every we've just been dealing
with them in the abstract right now but
you can imagine that these are kind of
the results of some type of experiment
let's say that I gave three different
types of pills or three different types
of food to people picking a test and
these are the scores on the test so this
is food food one
this is food one this is food two this
is food two and then this right over
here is food three food three and I want
to figure out if there's the type of
food that people take going into the
test does it really affect their scores
are the differences in the scores you
know if you look at these means it looks
like they perform best in group 3 then
in group two or then in Group one but is
that difference purely random random
chance or as am I pretty
can I be pretty confident that it's due
to actual differences in the population
means of all of the people who would
ever take food 3 versus food 2 versus
food 1 what I want to do is say you know
is so my question here is are the means
the true population means the same so if
the true population means this is a
sample mean just based on 3 samples but
if I knew the true population mean so my
question is is the mean of the
population of people taking food
one equal to the mean of food to
obviously I'll never be able to give
that food to every human being that
could ever live and then make them all
take an exam but we're trying to get a
sense of there is some true meaning
there it's just not really measurable
and so my question is this equal to this
equal to the mean three the true
population mean three and my question is
are these equal is because if they're
not equal and that means that the food
that the food actually the different
foods that you get actually Doug do have
some type of impact on how people
perform on a test so let's do a little
bit of a hypothesis test here so let's
say that my null hypothesis let's say
that my null hypothesis is that the
means are correct are the same our food
doesn't make a difference
food doesn't make a difference it the
food doesn't make a difference and that
my alternate hypothesis is that it does
it does and a way of thinking about this
a little quantitatively is that if it
doesn't make a difference the true
population means of the groups will be
the same so that means the true
population mean of the group that took
food 1 will be the same as a group that
took food 2 which will be the same as
the group that took as the group that
took food 3 if our alternate hypothesis
is correct then these means will not all
be the same so how can we how can we
test this hypothesis so what we're going
to do we're going to assume the null
hypothesis is what we always do in our
hypothesis testing we're going to assume
our null hypothesis and then essentially
figure out what is what are the chances
of getting a certain statistic this
extreme and I haven't even defined with
that statistic are so we're going to
define we're going to assume our null
hypothesis and then we're going to come
up with a statistic called the F
statistic so our F statistic which has
an F distribution and we won't go in
real deep into the details of the F
distribution but you can already start
to think of it as a ratio of two
chi-squared distributions that may or
may not have different degrees of
freedom our F statistic is
to be the ratio of our sum of squares
between the samples so it's going to be
our sum our total sum of I should say
sum of squares between divided by
divided by our degrees of freedom
between and sometimes this is called the
mean squares between MSB either way it's
going to be that divided by divided by
the sum of squares within so that's what
I had done up here the sum of squares
within in blue divided by the sum of
squares within sum of squares within
divided by the degrees of freedom of the
sum of squares within and that was M M
times n minus 1 now let's just think
about what this is doing right here if
this number if the numerator if the
numerator is much larger than the
denominator if it's much larger than the
denominator then what that tells us is
is that the variation in this data is
due mostly is due mostly to the
differences between the actual means and
it's due less due to the actual
variation within the means
that's if this numerator is much bigger
than this denominator over here so that
would make us believe that should make
us believe that there is a difference in
the true population mean so if this
number is really big it would should
tell us that there's a lower probability
that our that our null hypothesis is
correct if this number is really small
let's say that this is larger let's say
that our denominator is larger that
means that our variation within each
sample makes up more of the total
variation than a variation between the
samples so that means that our variation
within each of these samples is a bigger
percentage of the total variation versus
the variation between the sample so that
would make us believe that hey you know
any difference that we actually see in
the means is probably just random and
that would make it maybe a little harder
to reject our null hypothesis so let's
just actually calculate it for this so
in this case our sum of squares between
our sum of squares between we calculated
over here was 24 24 and we had two
degrees of freedom we had two degrees of
freedom and our
of squares within our sum of squares
within was six and we had how many
degrees of freedom we had how many
degrees of freedom our degrees of
freedom there were also six six degrees
of freedom right over there so there's
going to be 24 divided by 2 which is 12
divided by 1 divided by 1 so our F
statistic that we've calculated is going
to be equal to 12 and this stands for
Fisher who is the biologist and and a
statistician who came up with this
so our F statistic is going to be 12 and
what we're going to see is this is a
pretty high number now one thing I
forgot to mention any hypothesis test we
need to have some type of significance
level and so let's say the significance
level that we care about for our
hypothesis test is 10% is 0.1 zero which
means that if we assume if assuming the
null hypothesis there is less than a 10
percent chance of getting the result
that we got of getting this F statistic
then we will reject the null hypothesis
so what we want to do is figure out a
critical F statistic value that getting
that extreme of a value or greater is
10% and if this is bigger than our
critical f statistic value then we're
going to reject the null hypothesis if
it's less we can't reject the null
hypothesis and so I'm not going to go a
lot into the guts of the F statistic but
you can already appreciate this
each of these sum of squares has a
chi-squared distribution this has a
chi-squared distribution and this has a
different-colored distribution this is a
chi-squared distribution with two
degrees of freedom
it's a chi-squared distribution with and
we haven't normalized it in all of that
but roughly a chi-squared distribution
with six degrees of freedom so the F
statistic is actually the ratio or the F
distribution is the ratio of two
chi-squared distributions and I got this
this is a screenshot from a professor's
course at the UCLA hope they don't mind
I actually needed to find an F table for
us to look into but this is what an F
distribution looks like
and obviously it's going to look
different depending on the degrees of
freedom of the numerator and the
denominator there's kind of two degrees
of freedom to think about the numerators
degree of freedom and the denominators
degree of freedom
but with that said let's calculate let's
calculate the critical F statistic the
critical F statistic for alpha is equal
to zero point one zero and you're
actually going to see different F tables
for each different alpha where our
numerator degree of freedom is 2 and our
denominator degree of freedom is 6 so
this table that I got this whole table
is for an alpha or significance level of
10% or 0.1 zero and our numerators
degree of freedom was 2 and our
denominators degree to freedom is 6 so
our critical F value is 3 point 4 6
so our F so our critical F value is 3
point 4 6 so this right over here this
value right here is 3 point 4 6 the
value that we got based on our data is
much larger than that way above it it's
going to have a very very small p-value
the probability of getting something
this extreme just by chance assuming the
null hypothesis is very low it's far
it's way bigger than our critical F
statistic with a 10 percent significance
level so because of that we can reject
we can reject the null hypothesis which
leads us to believe that you know what
they're actually probably is a
difference in the population means which
tells us there probably is a difference
on the performance on an exam if you
give them the different foods